those of you who have not come across me
in the past my name is pete nest and i'm
going to be your host once again today
so this is the third and final session
of our first r studio cloud live series
now in terms of housekeeping
unlike prior events we're actually going
to start with a live cloud demo uh then
to follow um much like in the past we're
going to have a live q a
now there's no need to wait till the
demo is over feel free to ask any
questions along the way in the youtube
live chat
and at this point i'd actually like to
introduce my colleague mine
tinkaya rondell who is a professional
educator and a data scientist here at
our studio as well as a professor
in academia
i mean
hello uh thanks for having me here today
um and i'm excited to talk about our
studio cloud today so i use our studio
cloud both as part of my life at our
studio and also as an educator at duke
university as well and my goal today is
to talk to you a little bit about both
how i use our studio cloud for teaching
and also give you a little bit of tips
and tricks so let's go ahead and get
started all right um
oh
apologies for that
let's try that one more time
all right i think we can put it back on
screen now
great
um so um if you are interested in
getting a hold of these slides you can
find them at rstd.io
rs cloud dash demo
i will show this link at the end as well
and there will be a bunch of uh kind of
demos throughout so the slides only give
you a glimpse of part of what i'm going
to say but if you would like to get a
hold of the pdf you can do so there so
let's first talk a little bit about what
our studio cloud is um our studio cloud
looks just like this when you land on
rstudio.cloud and you log in um you can
see that you have a place for your
projects and you can start with a new
project
and we'll start with an rstudio project
for now and you'll see that in my
browser
i have something that looks just like
our studio if i had it locally on my
computer as well and i can give it a
name so that outer shell is a little bit
different than what i tend to have
locally
on my computer where i can get name my
projects but beyond that i have my
console i have my environment app
everything is as i know it what's
happening is that the compute is
happening on our studio cloud as opposed
to happening on my computer well what
that tells me is that if this lives on
the web i should be able to easily share
it with others as well so a lot of what
we're going to talk about today is how
not just how you create our studio cloud
projects but also how you share it with
others particularly in the context of
teaching how you share it with your
students
um but before we get there maybe let's
answer the question why would i want our
studio in the cloud in the first place
so instead of working locally why might
i want that well particularly in the
context of teaching if you are going to
be teaching are with our studio um
but your students are going to be using
our studio locally um they're going to
have to do a few things when they get to
the first class they're going to have to
install r they're going to have to
install rstudio and they're going to
have to install a bunch of packages that
you might use throughout the semester
um that's actually not that difficult
necessarily but you do have to utter
these words to them right these things
tend to work pretty relatively easily
for majority of us
but it becomes a thing you have to walk
them through before you get to the
exciting part of doing data analysis
then you also need to talk to them a
little bit about what's installing a
package versus loading a package and if
you like me teach with version control
you also have to get your students to
install git locally on their computers
as well
and
trying to hit all five of these major
bullet points in the first 10 minutes of
the class is probably not going to
happen realistically you'll end up
having to
set aside a bunch of time for it and
potentially do uh quite a bit of
debugging for maybe a small number of
your students but there will be some who
will get stuck on some of these stages
instead of starting off you're teaching
with lots of friction points you might
want to be living in this land with much
less friction where
you go to our studio.cloud in your
browser you log in and you can start
coding um what i'm always trying to get
my students to uh where i'm always
trying to get my students is a place
where when they sit down to work on
their computer and they're like all
right i'm gonna work on my stats or my
data science course
it doesn't take them more work to get
started than you know launching a video
on netflix for example and that's how
easily you can get started um with a
something like this
now we talked about why our studio in
the cloud so where they go to could be
our studio.cloud or could be other
options as well so how do we achieve an
access to our studio in the cloud
one option is using the rstudio
workbench which i'll just talk about
briefly here and then move away from but
there may be reasons why this is the
this may be what you prefer
so if you have
sysadmin experience yourself or it
support perhaps from your university
and you also have some either hardware
or a local virtual machine or some cloud
computing credit where you could be
running the compute and obviously you
yourself have a bit of our studio
experience to be teaching with it this
might be
an option for you so our studio offers
our studio workbench which you can run
um you know in your browser
um once it's been set up for you um and
you can get the software for um for
teaching purposes for free from our cdo
and i've put on the slide the link to
our academic pricing page if you'd like
to take a look to find out more about
that offering
um the if you would like to set things
up in this way there is a bit of setup
and that's why i have the first bullet
point about either having sysadmin
experience rit support available to you
but if those are things that you are
able to do and you are able to set
things up in a way that where your
students can authenticate and use the
platform um
do um you know um you may you may find
this um article we have in the american
statistician called infrastructure and
tools for teaching computing throughout
the statistical curriculum helpful where
we describe our setup that we have at
duke university where we use a version
of this setup for getting our students
to do uh computing in their browser
um another option is instead of having
to needing to have all three of these if
you just have our studio experience
yourself as an instructor but maybe not
the sysadmin experience and not the kind
of the machine where you could be
running this on our studio cloud might
be the right option for you so the setup
is
a lot less cumbersome and a lot less
resource intensive um so that's what
we're going to be mostly talking about
today
now that hopefully we've set the stage
for
there may be a pedagogical need for
getting your students to start computing
in the cloud as opposed to locally and
kind of giving you given you a lay of
the land of what are your options for
doing this with our studio um let's talk
a little bit more about why our studio
cloud beyond the fact that it does not
require it experience to set up it also
has some really nice bells and whistles
that are designed particularly for
teaching for example there is the notion
of a workspace uh where you can organize
your class as a workspace so either if
you're teaching multiple classes in the
same semester or from semester to
semester you're able to kind of um
have them organized in a nicely
contained way
there is a notion of roles so things
like instructor teaching assistant or
student can be assigned to particular
roles on our studio cloud
you can turn your project so i just
showed you earlier how to fire up a
project in our studio cloud you can turn
that into an assignment that your
students can
quickly get started with and as an
instructor something i really really
like is that you can peek into student
projects
so that is really very similar to being
able to you know be say in a computer
lab with your students and um if they
have a question kind of peeking over
their shoulder um and being able to do
this has been particularly
helpful when we've had to do a bunch of
remote teaching
um the other thing is that you can set
up a base project that contains any r
packages you might need or any other
documentation that you would like for
your students to have at every um for
for every single one of their projects
you can set that up for them and modify
it throughout the semester and ensure
that each time a student starts a new
project they're all starting with the
same base project
um certain system libraries work out of
the box for example uh
git will work out of the box um and also
you can render to pdf or word and that
works out of the box as well these are
generally things for local uh use the
user would have to set up themselves or
if you are teaching uh in a situation
where your students are um using their
local
setup they would have to install for
themselves and usually the installation
and setup of these tends to require more
skills than just being able to do some
computing with r
all right so now that we've kind of done
an introduction to our studio cloud i'd
like to do a few demos where i can
actually take you through our studio
cloud and talk a little bit uh and show
you a little bit about how life in our
studio cloud works so let's start with
this uh notion of a project so this is
what an rstudio project uh our studio
cloud project looks like um and here i
am in an r studio session and the um if
you do use our studio locally as well um
this is basically the same idea as a
local project um
and there's a nice ui as i said up top
or as a banner where you can kind of
keep track of which project you're
working on
um
another thing that you can do is so when
we're starting up a new project you can
actually open up a jupiter project as
well so this is currently in beta but it
is available and when you fire this up
you basically get an ipython notebook
and you can see that in the same
environment so i've just i'm still in
our studio cloud but i'm able to run a
jupiter notebook as well
and you can see just like a regular
jupiter notebook i have a little bit of
kind of text and a little bit of code
intermingled and i can run my cells so
on and so forth
other things that you can do is you can
also start with a project from a git
repository so you can simply put the um
kind of the url of your git repository
here i'm cloning the praise package that
is an our package that you know gives
you nice pleasantries as you run your
code gives you some positive uh
reinforcement and you can see that i'm
able to clone that project and kind of
start working with that as well uh this
does require um
that you uh kind of sync up your github
account with your rstudio cloud account
which you can do so uh from your profile
but once that's all set up you're able
to interact with git easily as well
um so
teaching with our studio cloud beyond
just using it for yourself really does
not require any further um kind of setup
than this except the fact that you
probably will want to
prepare some projects for your students
and you might be thinking about various
ways that you can share it with them so
um there are really two ways that i
think about teaching when i'm kind of
thinking about
what sort of
sharing approach i'm going to use for my
students often i ask myself the question
is this a shorter engagement something
like a workshop or a short course where
i can organize content in a single r
studio project or just a few projects
and i have no need for keeping track of
my learner so that's usually for me a
setting where maybe i won't be grading
them or i'm not necessarily responsible
for keeping track of their work over an
extended period of time
if that's the case you can simply create
a project like we've shown before and
share that project simply by sharing its
url
if you have a longer engagement so that
is perhaps a semester-long course or a
multi-day workshop where there's lots of
content and instead of kind of putting
all of that into a single or just a few
our studio uh projects you can think
about it as many many projects that need
to happen throughout a semester so maybe
many homework assignments a final
project some lab work so on and so forth
and you have a need or desire to keep
track of your learners either for
grading purposes or because you want to
assess either for your um kind of
enjoyment or
to be able to give feedback to the
students how much they're interacting
with
with both the platform and also the
learning materials that you've prepared
for them in that case i recommend
creating a workspace and then inviting
your students to that workspace so i'm
going to demo both of these approaches
next so let's start with
sharing in our studio cloud project so
we're in the instructor view here you
can see that i have prepared a single or
studio project and i have a few folders
in there where i've organized my
teaching materials this happens to be a
short course i gave on introduction to
shiny so we have four modules in this
short course and i've created those and
put them in my files pane
um and what i'm going to do
is um i can kind of show you the inside
these folders we can see that i have
kind of the um the r scripts that i want
to share with my learners
and
i also have packages installed as well
so um i am installing any packages that
i'm going to use in this uh short course
for my uh students so that when they
come in they can simply run the code and
they don't have to worry about
installing packages as well it's not
that difficult to install packages but
this ensures that everybody is using the
same version of the package
i have prepared everything for them and
what i can do next is make my project
shareable it's private by default but i
can go to access and say anyone can
share view this project now
um and just grab its url now when i say
anyone can view the project i should
mention that even though anyone can now
see this it's only if i share the url
with them it's kind of privacy by
obscurity you can see that url has some
random numbers at the end and just about
anyone couldn't just guess what that is
obviously so um
so we where i'm going to have to kind of
grab that url now that i've enabled
sharing and then i
share that with my learners uh so i
maybe email it to them or message it to
them or something and all they need to
do is put that in their browser and
they're going to need to log in
they might choose to log in with google
or github or something else
or like an rcdo cloud account
um and you can see that they're in the
same um kind of looking environment and
they don't need to install a package
anymore they can simply load a package
because the package for them is already
installed and they have the in same file
structure as i have um and they're able
to run the code i want to grab your
attention to or point your attention to
one more thing here just under student
view on my slide it says temporary copy
so when a student receives this link
they're in a temporary copy of this
project
and what they can do is next to that
there's a button that says save a
permanent copy and they can make it
their own at that point our cdo cloud is
simply grabbing a snapshot of that
project and making a copy for the
student that they can continue working
on and when they come back
they're able to continue working on
their own copy and any changes they make
basically does not propagate back to my
project
and also does not get lost either
so this idea of sharing in our studio
cloud project on the plus side is super
easy first of all i created my project
and all i had to do was to flip a switch
for shareability and share the url um
other pluses associated with it is that
students land directly in a project upon
login so you know we're telling them
we're teaching our studio and we give
them a url and they're right there
there's no additional steps they need to
do
um i find that beyond teaching um this
sort of pro sharing a project is
actually great for just collaboration uh
particularly if i have collaborators
with whom i'm want to share my code but
maybe they're not you know git or github
users so that's not the path we want to
go or to create some reproducible
examples that might be a bit more
um
you know
a bit more extensive than like a little
snippet you might share with somebody on
slack or github so oftentimes if i'm
trying to debug for example an extensive
shiny app even if i make it pretty
minimal i find that there's a lot of
code there to just post into a message
so often i'll create a single our studio
cloud project and then it ends up having
the packages that i have installed ready
to go as well to share with somebody
else to ask a question
now on the negative side um that
temporary copy thing with even with the
handy save a permanent copy button next
to it can sometimes get students because
they need to remember to make a
permanent copy of the project
um which honestly as an instructor to
you means you need to remind them to do
so um otherwise their work can get lost
um
also as an instructor you can't keep
track of which students started their
assignments because once they make a
copy they own that and they um if they
want you to take a look at their project
you need to be granted permission back
you don't have that by default even
though you have originally shared it
with them
the permanent other things that could be
a plus or a minus
depending on your situation is that
these permanent projects once the
student has make makes the permanent
project they count towards their
students free account so if you're an
instructor who is not wanting to kind of
use up your accounts usage um this that
might be a plus
or if you're an instructor who is
thinking i would like to make sure that
i'm offering this to my students um you
know for free forever this may not be
the right setup for you
also students control permissions on
their project this can also be a pro or
a con
it's nice for them to have this control
but that might also mean that they are
sharing it very liberally so if you're
teaching in a
setting where um you know things like
maybe giving an assignment that students
should not be collaborating on in any
way should not see each other's code
this might make it easier for them to do
something that they're not supposed to
do obviously uh you know disallowing
this sort of permission
permissions from the students does not
mean you're going to be ensured that no
academic dishonesty occurs but generally
my motto when i'm teaching is i try to
not make it additionally easier for my
students to do something that i don't
want them to do so if you're giving
assignments and you're saying you can't
see each other's code
this may again may not be the right
approach for you
um so we've talked about creating a
single project and sharing that and i
mentioned that this is a useful approach
for kind of short engagements but what
about for longer engagements where
maybe you're teaching a semester long
course and you need things a little
better organized so in that case the
approach that you might take is inviting
your students to an rstudio cloud
workspace
so i'm again here on the instructor view
and you can say that on top
on the top bar it says your workspace
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
click on the little menu next to it and
create a new space so in this case i'm
creating a space for a new course that
i'm giving um i'll call that shiny
essentials and now that i have moved
into this new workspace i can create
projects in here um so these projects
are only going to be accessible to folks
that are in this workspace so i can
similarly uh create modules um for my um
students to learn from
and i can set things up in um in
many ways um so when i go to share this
project you can see that it now says
everyone in shiny essentials and it
allows me to turn it into an assignment
as well
what this means is when the students
land in this workspace
they're going to see this first project
and it says instead of assignment next
to it it will say start for them so they
can get started with a permanent copy of
their own that lives in this rstudio
cloud workspace so they don't have to
remember to you know make a copy for
themselves
um once students have uh started their
assignments
i as the instructor can track their
projects as well so in this case i was
teaching this shiny essentials course um
and over the four modules you can see
that there are uh there are many uh kind
of derived projects from each of these
so
187 students
came to this project and they made their
own permanent copies and they started
working on them and i can actually go in
click on that view derived projects um
link and i can go in and see my students
names and even open up their our studio
cloud project so if somebody is having
difficulty to the point where we're
unable to like help them get unstuck by
you know maybe discussion forum posts or
something i can actually go in and
directly help them in their our studio
session
um another thing is um so how do we get
students into this workspace um under
the members tab within your uh workspace
you can see the names of your members so
i have grade those out for privacy
reasons but you can see that i can
scroll through and see who the members
are of this workspace and i can invite
more folks either via an invitation so i
would need to enter their email address
and send it to them or i can use a
sharing link so i can create a sharing
link set a particular default role for
that sharing link and simply share the
link with them
and at some point i can reset that link
if i want if i want no further people to
continue to join the workspace
so these particular roles are admin
moderator contributor and viewer
i think about these as the admin is the
instructor so that's me i can do
whatever i want i can manage users i can
view edit and manage all of the projects
um the moderator level to me uh in an
instructional setting is more like my ta
they can view edit and manage all
projects but they don't have the
privileges to
get more people in or kick people out of
the class
a contributor are my students they can
create edit and manage their own
projects only they don't get to touch
other people's projects and then the
viewer role is something that i think
that you know that you may not even use
at all but instances where i've used it
have been either auditors to the class
or um guests so these people can only
view projects that are shared with
everyone and no other projects um
sometimes i have colleagues who want to
um
who want to
perhaps take a peek at what's happening
in my class uh to kind of take a look to
see how i've set up my um
rstudio uh cloud workspace for example
but i perhaps don't want them to see my
students names or or their projects so
that's the role i have mostly used on
that for
um we can also set permissions and these
come unchecked by default and i would
recommend leaving them that way unless
you have good reason to do so one of
them for example is about whether
contributors can see the members list
another one is whether they can
contributors can make their projects
visible to all members i usually leave
that unchecked because i don't want my
students to readily share their
assignments with each other
and then there's uh other settings in
terms of what the viewers can do and who
can change the computational resources
and i'll talk a little bit about what i
mean by computational resources in a
little bit
another um
perk of using this workspace setting is
perhaps my favorite one
is this notion of a base r studio
project so what that is is a project
that you can set so it's an r studio uh
project that you can set to say this is
the image i want every single project to
start with
so i can actually uh put decide on the
version of r i want everyone to use the
installed packages and their versions
that i want everyone to use and also any
files that i want every single project
in my workspace to contain
usually for me those are things like a
statement of code of conduct uh maybe
some instructions for how to submit work
um they're not things that change from
assignment to assignment they're things
that need to stay constant they're the
sort of things you might tell your
students go read in the syllabus so i
end up putting those there
um
these base projects can be updated
throughout the semester uh which means
that say a newer version of a package
you use comes and you want to be able to
teach with the newer functionality
that's been implemented mid-semester you
can update the base project so that
going forward you're using a newer
version of that package and every
project that's starting from that point
onwards is affected by this update but
it's not retroactive and that's good
because you're not going to break old
work students may have done
um i think this is also a really nice um
perk because um when you are using kind
of maybe an rcdo in the server type
setup that may be shared um throughout
the university or throughout your
department with maybe other instructors
oftentimes it professionals would be
hesitant to update this sort of base
image because changes that you make
could affect others as well but by then
by the definition of a workspace it's
only your class and you're the um only
per your class is the only um set of
projects who are going to be affected by
this change so you really can do as you
please
um so let's talk a little bit about the
pros and cons of this approach as well
we talked about various permission
levels as a pro and this notion of a
base project um the notion of
assignments which remove the need to
remind students to make copy of their
projects before starting their work
and um the ability to peek into student
projects and ability to view stats on
student engagement so you can take a
look at the dashboard to see how much
kind of compute your students may have
been using and i'll mention in a second
that we have a package that you can use
to speak to the r studio cloud api to
get further information about which of
your students have been active
i know a few folks are using that sort
of data for pedagogical research for
example to quantify engagement of
students with the um
with the work
in the negative side perhaps if i could
pick on something and i think really
here the negatives are very small
is that when students land in a
workspace when they get invited they
just land in that main page not in an r
studio project so you're going to want
to spend a minute or two orienting your
students about what they need to do next
but that's the sort of thing you really
need to say once and then it's quite
clear to them what they need to do the
next time they get there
when we talk about things that could be
pros or cons
the student work counts towards the
instructor or the institution workspace
hours um that means that if you if the
kind of the free uh plan is not
sufficient for the amount of work your
students are doing um which very well
might be the case if this is like a
semester-long course you need to have
set up things where the um
student uh so their hours will count uh
towards the limits that you have set up
for your workspace
um also another one that could be a pro
or a con is that instructor controls
permission of students projects so um if
you are running a course where you want
things to be readily shareable
you would perhaps check that box the
permission box to allow your students to
um
you know make their projects shareable
um but by default it would not be the
case
um so now that we've talked a little bit
about how to get students into your rcdo
cloud space and how to share um your
materials with them i'll kind of try to
wrap things up um but with some tips
before we perhaps move into a bit of a q
a um so the first tip that i would um
mention is that changes to an assignment
that you make um that after a student
has started one propagate to their copy
so this is not like google docs in a way
is i think the best way to describe it
when your student makes a copy of a
project you've set up for them in either
of the sharing approaches they're really
taking a snapshot at that time so if you
need to change your assignment and i'm
sure we've all been there you assign a
homework assignment then you realize
something is wrong you're going to need
to get that information to them in
another way or have them start with a
new project or have your projects be
linked to a git repository as well
and you can change that git repository
and ask your students to pull the
changes in
um packages in the base project are
installed but not loaded so when you're
writing your instructions you want to
remind yourself i remind your students
to do library whatever package name uh
because they won't be able to use it
immediately in the console
um the late this information is always
on the rstudio cloud guide and the
what's new page um our studio cloud is
still evolving
it is not um changing um in terms of um
it's not changing in terms of like in a
way where it's going to be a completely
different ui the next day your students
land in it but there are new features uh
being added um and so it's nice to keep
up with those
and if you encounter any sort of
slowness or glitches say your students
are reporting we can't log on um there's
a current system status um link on the
side that's super handy it allows you to
check to see if they're a real outage
and if not you can go ahead and report
it
other tips is i strongly recommend
creating an additional account so i have
this like additional account with
another personal email address i had and
i invite that
persona as a student so as a contributor
into my workspace so that i can login
log in and see things um the students
see them that can be helpful when you
are um kind of taking screenshots for
your students as well if that's the sort
of thing you like to put in your
instructions
um you can set computational resources
allowed to projects
by default um you get a decent amount
but if you're working with either bigger
data sets
or um
you know or doing something that's more
computationally intensive
uh
then the default uh settings would be
sufficient for um you may want to up
those computational resources um that
are um available to each project and the
one way to figure out if this is going
to be needed is to actually test your
assignment so if you write answer keys
for example you may try running them in
our studio cloud to make sure things
hold up the one place where this can be
difficult to foresee ahead of time can
be if you have open-ended projects for
your students because then maybe you
have no control over exactly what
they're going to work on how big a data
set they're going to bring so it's nice
to have a feedback loop and explain to
your students a little bit um
that if things are lagging or slow or
just like they're trying to run some
code or things and are hanging it very
well might be that the resources allowed
it aren't sufficient and they can bring
that up to you and you can set that for
them after they've started the project
as well so those are things you can
change at any point in a project's life
um i would the peeking at your students
functionality is super nice but from a
pedagogical perspective i would
recommend uh that you use that feature
sparingly it's important for us to teach
our students how to ask good questions
without us saying hey just move away
from the keyboard i'll do it for you
because that's a little bit of that move
away from the computer let me take over
and do it and sometimes that's exactly
what a student needs um but it's useful
for them to try to articulate the
question first and not go there right
away
i also use that assignment feature for
things that are not assignments as well
so even if i don't necessarily expect
the students to complete and turn in
something um you might still use that
feature because it's just a handy
feature to say let me get started with
where you left things off and so one of
the things i do is if i'm doing any sort
of live coding in class i'll create a
skeleton of what i'm going to get
through maybe with some prompts
throughout an our markdown file and
leave that as an r studio cloud project
for students to get started with as i
start coding as well
um there are various uh kind of plans
that you uh can choose for our studio
cloud and there's a free plan as well
and for kind of either hobby usage or
kind of short
amounts of teaching that what's allowed
there um a lot of there might very well
be sufficient but i've found that if i'm
teaching a course with many students
over a 15-week semester i probably need
either the instructor or the
organization plan and if there are
questions about the
if there are questions about the um
these various plans i will be able to
answer them at the end as well
um i'll also mention the rs cloud
package um it's not currently on cran
but it is available on github and our
goal is to get that on cran perhaps
sometimes in 2022
but it has a nice set of functions where
as you can see you can query the api to
get a list of your users to get some
information on their statistics like are
they still engaging or not um you can
use it to send invitations uh so it's
almost like you get to upload a roster
and send invitations to all of your
students so if you are um
using our studio cloud heavily and
particularly with large groups of uh
members and students um the package
might very well be helpful for you
especially if you're like me and you
don't like clicking around things too
much and you'd rather script things up
um if you have if you do start working
with rs cloud you're going to need an
api key which you can get uh in the rcdo
cloud ui so just from your profile you
can go ahead and request an api key and
if there's features that you would like
to see in this package please open an
issue i'm actively working on it and
we'd be happy to try to implement them
or at least let you know if that's not
feasible uh due to the setup of the api
and if you would like to learn more
about our studio cloud uh jesse master
pack has put together this really nice
uh playlist of uh kind of short videos
on youtube that are about you know
individual things you might want to do
on our studio cloud um
so um i recommend taking a look at that
as well um i think there may be there
may be stuff you're familiar with but
sometimes nice to see how somebody else
approaches it and there very well might
be things that you didn't know existed
there as well
all right i think that's it from me once
again the slides for this can be found
at rstd.io
rs cloud demo and i would be happy to
take any questions
thanks for listening
hey me nate thank you so much that was
uh super interesting hopefully our guest
walked away learning something new
in terms of q a i think we have a few
lined up for anyone that might have
joined a little late if you do have any
questions
feel free to enter those on the youtube
live chat and we'll we'll be sure to
surface them
i'm going to start with a question that
i actually get pretty often let me get
this up on the screen here so i get
asked a lot about base projects could
you talk a little bit more about how you
handled those scenarios uh before the
base project concept existed
yeah so if if i don't have access to
this notion of a base project uh what
that means is that every time i set up
an assignment i have to install the
packages that are needed for that
assignment for me that often means i
need to install tidy verse for example
so homework one install tidy where's
homework to install tidywares and any
other projects as well
another thing is submission instructions
is also another thing that comes up a
lot like or any sort of like um you know
these are the things you're allowed to
do for this assignment these are the
things you're not allowed to do so i
would have this like text file um
that's like a plain text file that has
this information that i would upload to
every single uh assignment um the way i
tend to teach in a workspace my students
are
rarely creating a project
just out of the blue in there they're
often starting off of an assignment that
i have prepared for them so the base
projects have mostly made my life easier
as i create new assignments um but every
once in a while there may be a situation
where your student just wants to create
a project in there and work on something
related to the class but maybe not
necessarily attached to any assignment
and then they get the benefit of using
the same r version and the version of
packages that you have pre-installed for
them as well
the other thing that i really like about
the base projects is that i can update
them throughout the semester and they
don't break uh projects that happen in
the past so student work doesn't get
affected but i get to benefit from say a
new update that may have come up in a
package
interesting uh i see brad just sent over
a question that i think you somewhat
touched on but just to make sure
that they heard the answer is there a
way to distribute data files to students
without setting up a project
so if you're not setting up a project so
if you're setting up a project upload it
there and then it's distributed if
you're not setting up a project
um there isn't necessarily a r studio
cloud specific way of um getting it to
them but
ways that you might use is if you have
access to a place where you can upload
your data sets and that very well might
just be a github repository that would
be a free place to host them for example
um you can you know post them there and
then a lot of the data reading functions
will take a url as an input as well so
even if the data set doesn't exist um i
don't want to use the word locally i
suppose everything is in the cloud but
in that project for those students um
they can read directly from a url as
well um also
if the goal is to teach students how to
get data into something what you might
do is so this is something i've done as
well where sometimes i don't want to
just put the file the data files for
them into their files pane i want them
to learn how to do that so what i'll do
in my instructions is i'll have
instructions for downloading a data set
onto their computer so that we can teach
them how to upload a data set into the
rstudio cloud project and the reason why
i do that with some of my earlier
assignments is that for their final
project they have to find a data set and
bring it in so i want to make sure that
they have had some practice with
bringing in their own data set before we
get to that point
that makes a ton of sense uh looks like
the next question lots of instructors
use a learning management system so
curious how have you handled grading
um so
the way i have been teaching over the
last five or six years is that i
actually teach
version control alongside data science
and every single assignment is not only
an rstudio cloud project but it's also a
github repository and so we actually do
our submission in a way or grading by
pushing to github ultimately um there is
currently not a grading feature in our
studio cloud so there's not a way where
you like maybe assigned to each project
you know not a place where you can
actually store
a grade with it but i believe that's
like
in the pipeline of at least feature
requests that has come uh from um
from other instructors as well so that
very well might be something that's um
included later even in instances where
we've had grading but no like uh version
control or github associated with my
teaching i would have either myself or
my tas go into the particular projects
and the nice thing is if you have an
assignment that you have set up the
title of that assignment is always the
same i guess your students could mess
you up and change them but they
generally don't so what you end up
seeing is let's say your homework one
and then you can see as i saw on just
show on my slides like view derived
projects and you can go through go into
your students um
projects
grade their work and oftentimes what
i'll have is like a csv file i keep
locally where i enter the final grades
you can create new files in their um
projects as well to leave them feedback
if you would like to as well
you i see ryan just sent across the
question
uh would you recommend a particular pki
key management package that works well
with rcdo cloud
say like i'm pulling data from qualtrics
i have to ask what pki is because i'm
not sure what it stands for but maybe i
could find out for myself
uh or maybe it'll come in in the chat
ryan if you can clarify what pki is i
would be happy to
um try to answer that question public
key infrastructure i think maybe is what
it is um
hmm good question so this would be
something where you basically want to um
store some sort of public key in your
project
um i think i'm gonna say the closest i
have
experience i have to this is um
you know
maybe storing my
um personal access token for github
which you can do so however you're
storing these in an r session um if
you're working locally you should be
able to do so on our studio cloud as
well one thing i'll mention is um any
sort of user level information as such
does not get shared between your
projects in your rstudio cloud profile
so you would have to set those things on
a per project basis which can be a
hassle or it might be actually a
positive if you're actually trying to
test you know access levels with various
keys um
but
and i i don't i don't have a
recommendation for a specific package
but whatever has worked for you locally
should work on our studio cloud as well
for that
thanks mina i see ryan did confirm uh
that meant public keys
uh next question looks like from uh
vancouver british columbia
is there a way to integrate with nb
greater
um
not to my knowledge as of now but that
being said i am not a heavy and big
grader user so don't you know full quote
me on that um
so the
one thing that you know i know that um
nb grader works very nicely with jupiter
notebook so i don't think our studio
cloud has like a specific thing for nb
grader as of today that being said
however you tend to set up and be
greater for grading from like jupiter
notebooks should work here as well
um
[Music]
i don't know how you would handle things
where you hide the tests from your
students but as long as all of that
stuff can live in the same session it
could be using the same compute and
would could still be giving the
automated feedback
interesting while we're
on the topic i'm curious about a single
sign-on uh here's the question my school
requires sso can our studio cloud
integrate with my school's existing
authentication setup
i think the answer is yes
the answer is
yeah yeah yeah so you might know more
about this because you work with various
other schools pete
yeah yeah i'm happy to speak to that so
uh depending on your school's existing
sso setup um we very likely can
integrate with it i know some of the
popular ones are shibboleth and
saml and if you're using something else
please feel free to reach out i know
some institutions utilize google off
which is another one
that should not be an issue
and
keeping up with the current topics you
mentioned jupiter so is it true you
could access jupiter notebooks with our
studio cloud
yes i believe this is still in beta but
you can
request that access uh right if you have
a paid plan i think maybe you can
request that so it is true and it is
trickling down the pipeline to be like i
think uh just as much of as a our studio
project the first class citizen there
but it is certainly working yeah
great yeah and just uh for folks out
there that are interested it is
currently in beta we will uh be
transitioning to general availability by
end of this quarter and as mine said if
you're on a paid tier you can get access
to the beta and even if you're not on a
page here if you have a use case you're
super interested in you know trying out
with that just feel free to shoot us an
email
it's
pete
rstudio.com
and
we can see if we can set you up
regardless
looks like we have a few more questions
trickling in
uh here we go
a while ago i noticed hitches taking
hours to install all packages when
opening my rstudio cloud project in
ubuntu
that i created in windows
um so i think that
i i don't know that that's necessarily
like a problem of you know being created
in one
operating system and then opening in
another i i would imagine that that is
not the cause of that
uh that is not the cause of that um but
it is true that the package install was
taking a bit longer um
i don't know if this is currently in the
deployed version of it but i know that
some changes have happened very um
recently in our studio cloud where all
of that stuff should be working a little
bit faster right now and one thing i'll
say is that there's this um to our
product our studio package manager that
has made like package installation and
keeping track of versions for kind of
whatever your setup might be a lot
easier for various folks and whatever
advances are happening
in that are kind of like the goal is to
absorb them into our studio cloud as
much as possible so you should be seeing
uh speed up there
another thing i will mention though this
may be only relevant if you are kind of
um
uh using this in the teaching context
perhaps but
even if things take a while if you use
this notion of a base project things
take a while only once which is i think
another nice thing that each person
starting up a project doesn't have to
wait through
the installation of those only the first
time you install them into the base you
may wait through it and then the rest
should work more quickly
thank you uh let's see is
real time collaborative coding coming to
our studio cloud
i think that is coming that is certainly
well it is my personally most
highly requested feature whenever i'm
asked what would you like to see there
that's literally the first thing i say
and of course it's coming from others as
well um and yes that is certainly
something the team is working on i'm
really excited to see what it might look
like i hope we'll be able to catch a
glimpse of that sometime in this year
yeah so i i can tell you from my
perspective that our team is is working
on that and i believe the plan
uh similar to the the jupiter notebooks
is to have that available uh by the end
of porter but we'll we'll certainly keep
folks up to date as that progresses
um
let's see
here we go from robert i would like to
see a demo of the rs cloud package for
management will that be offered anytime
soon this would be very useful for us to
leverage here
um so
uh like uh
uh like a demo on using the rs cloud
package in terms of what you can do with
that
i think that's the question right i
believe that's the question and mina
correct me if i'm wrong but i believe we
do have a at least a brief video
recording of how you can use that um we
could certainly surface that and if
there's something additional uh robert
that you might be looking for
please feel free to follow up with us
again my email is pete as in peter
rstudio.com and we can certainly set up
something for you
yeah so one of the videos that where i
showed on that playlist that jesse had
made is about rs cloud and i think that
you know if if this seems like a useful
thing to do like my goal is to try to
get that package on cran sometime this
year it's currently functional but there
are a few feature requests in there um
that we haven't done maybe when we do
that we can try to do one of these where
we do a more extensive um kind of demo
of it as well
perfect
brad i did see your question regarding
how our students count it
it really depends on your
your membership type
so happy to take that offline i just
threw my email in there if you want to
follow up with me and we can clarify
that for your particular use case
let's see we have about five more
minutes
here is a good one do instructors have
to cover all students costs
i think the answer is no it really
depends on
how you want to approach this so i will
i will tell you about my experience of
the various things that we've done like
kind of on the instructor side and then
pete might have more to add on that as
well um i think that um one of the
things you may want to consider is am i
the only instructor at my institution
who is doing this or are there other
instructors as well say various courses
in a given department because this
notion of instead of an instructor
account an organization account might
actually be the right fit for you
especially if you have students who are
taking like multiple classes for which
they might be using our studio cloud for
that was the setup that we had um last
year when i was at the university of
edinburgh
and i believe coming down the pipeline
if it's not live now is a notion where
students could pay for access even
though they're in your workspace right
pete
that's correct so historically
the instructor
again depending on membership type is
either going to cover the cost the
school is going to cover the cost or if
the students do directly cover the cost
today there might not actually be an
integration between the student's
account and the instructor's account
which as you can imagine can be a little
limiting when it comes to nice features
like being able to peek in and see how
your students are doing uh so as mean a
just um alluded to we are working on a
new plan where if you'd like um students
could actually pay for their actual
usage uh so so there's going to be more
options for for how to spin up our
studio cloud for your particular use
case at your institution we're hoping to
provide that new option in the next week
or two if things stay on track
let's see so a couple more minutes here
do have a few more questions trickling
in
to try our studio cloud is the free tier
robust or should i trial a paid tier
i think that the fear free tiers there
is no
i mean in terms of what things that i
would consider robustness there should
be no reason why you can't try things
out with the free tier i think you end
up running into limitations of the free
tier really when you are trying to offer
a particular type of experience to
either a large group of people or over
an extended period of time so i know
from an instructional perspective lots
of folks who run short courses or
workshops who just use the free tier for
that
yeah in my experience the free tier is
not really too limiting in terms of
features or capabilities it's more so
the amount of time you have access to it
in a given month and the amount of
collaborators users that you could share
projects with
um
let's see so depending on course type
does it make sense to use cloud for the
entirety of the course or to have
students transition to local machines at
some point
so that's a really good question and a
question that often comes up i'm often
like whenever i make a pitch for let's
teach on the cloud the first thing is
but don't they need to learn to install
and potentially yes so first of all i'll
couch this with well it really depends
on the learning goals of your course
right if part of the learning goals of
your course is software installation
then yes it does
make sense to transition i'll give you
my perspective of someone who
generally uses
a teaches introductory courses
i like starting things on the cloud and
one of the things that i try to make
sure that the students understand is
that the cloud is not just this esoteric
thing it actually is somebody else's
machine so we want to make sure that
before students leave your course they
understand what it means for things to
live on the cloud which means if they
then get involved with say a research
project that might have private data
associated with it they shouldn't just
upload it to our studio cloud without
making sure that that's okay so i think
it's important to explain to students
what that is um if you would like to
teach installation as part of it because
you think that would be a useful thing
for students to learn um maybe to
continue to engage with our studio down
the line even if they're not taking a
course
that uses any of this cloud access then
absolutely i think it's super helpful to
point them to resources or take a bit of
class time to do it and the nice thing
about doing it later is that they're not
both new to r and installation issues so
they are going to be able to distinguish
between what is an r error versus what
might be an error that might be
happening due to my setup um so i think
that doing that a later on in the course
um can have some of those benefits and
the last thing i'll say on this is
when people then go on to do things past
university life chances are they're
going to continue to do it on the cloud
i mean i think very few industry jobs
allow you to just like bring your own
laptop and compute on it and also a lot
of academic computing all happens on
research computing clusters as well so
this notion of doing things on the cloud
happens to ease onboarding but it's not
just some baby steps thing that's not a
realistic situation i think
interesting so we're coming down to the
last minute here so just one final
question that i think should be pretty
straightforward does workbench have the
same virtual classroom capability which
cloud provides
um i'm gonna say yes and no absolutely
yes in the sense that um you can have
like packages pre-installed for your
students and you can um uh you can put
some files in there right and then they
can just have them as well you can like
associate it with a file system and they
can authenticate and work there the no
part is really on the ui i think so you
don't have this notion of projects the
same way our studio cloud projects we
could see on the user interface of the
learning page there's not a lot notion
of an assignment either uh so there are
some of these kind of the nice bells and
whistles are various roles these are not
things that you are going to have by
default with workbench but does it allow
compute on the cloud with the rstudio
ide interface absolutely
awesome well mene it looks like we're at
time really appreciate this and again i
hope all folks that joined and were able
to tune in and ask questions um walked
away learning something new
if anyone was um only able to come on
for the last couple minutes we did
record this so it'll be fully available
shortly and again this is our last event
in this live cloud series we are hoping
to do another live cloud series in a few
months
and with that i will wish everyone a
good day